alors on s'en va en Ukraine parler de la
bataille de barthout qui est devenu puis
vous avez suivi au cours des dernières
semaines qui est devenu qu'une valeur
symbolique et une valeur stratégique
c'est ce que je vais demander au colonel
d'une colonel de l'armée française
exclutant Guillaume mancelle
lieutenant-colonel bonsoir
bonsoir Patrice alors Bart mot
les Russes encercle à peu près
entièrement le groupe Wagner
parlez-moi d'abord on verra l'issue mais
parlez-moi d'abord de la valeur
symbolique et stratégique de cette ville
en Ukraine
c'est effectivement une bataille qui est
très particulière cette bataille de bac
mouth parce que en réalité jusqu'ici les
Russes n'ont encaissé que des échecs
dont cette tentative d'invasion
l'Ukraine que ce soit Kiev puis dans le
Nord puis dans le sud Carson où ils ont
toujours de se retirer en novembre et en
fait ils veulent absolument offrir les
armées russes une victoire symbolique à
Vladimir Poutine pour justifier que
c'est invasions n'est pas justement
qu'un échec ou en tout cas la chronique
d'un échec totalement annoncé alors ils
se sont totalement concentrés sur
backwood attention vous disiez tout à
l'heure que c'était Wagner en réalité
Wagner opère avec l'armée russe ils sont
complètement coordonnés tout ce qui est
artillerie tout ce qui est attaque
aérienne bien sûr c'est l'armée russe
qui opère Wagner est juste un fantoche
qu'on agite devant soi et qui permet
d'occuper la scène médiatique mais
l'homme que vous montrez là à l'instant
aucun poids en réalité dans cette
opération c'est ce sont les armées
russes qui opère et comme vous l'avez
très bien montré tout à l'heure sur la
carte en fait les Russes essayent de
créer un mouvement comme une mâchoire
qui se referme sur la ville de
backgroute mais leur but en réalité
c'est que les Ukrainiens viennent se
faire prendre dans ce piège parce que ce
qu'il souhaite c'est pouvoir abîmer la
force blindée que sont en train de
monter les Ukrainiens pour lancer une
contre-offensive au printemps et donc
vous voyez dans cette mâchoire que
constitue maintenant batmouth en rouge
les Russes espérer que les Ukrainiens
viennent se précipiter c'est très
difficile de savoir à ce stade ce qu’on
vraiment décidé les Ukrainiens de mon
côté les informations que j'ai c'est que
les 50 pays alliés qui soutiennent les
Ukrainiens l'auront vivement conseillé
de ne surtout pas se précipiter dans ce
siège mais au contraire de défendre et
de laisser le terrain très
progressivement aux Russes en leur
infligeant un maximum de pertes mais de
ne pas engager leur nouvelle force
blindée les Ukrainiens disent un peu le
contraire ils affirment que ils vont
lancer des renforts qui vont continuer à
se battre je pense que c'est une pure
des informations à destination des
Russes qu'en réalité il se contente
d'envoyer le strict nécessaire sur
backmouth pour pouvoir contre attaquer
beaucoup plus loin sur le front un
endroit où les Russes ne les
attendraient pas ce serait une erreur
tactique terrible de lancer leur force
pour les Ukrainiens au seul endroit où
les Russes ont concentré leur propre
force parce que là la bataille serait
inégale et risquerait à ce moment-là de
se faire laminer par l'artillerie et les
avions et l'hélicoptères d'attaque russe
donc vous dites que c'était un piège et
essentiellement des Russes pour attirer
les forces ukrainiennes et refermez
ensuite et détruire le plus de de char
et de matériel possible
oui parce que en fait en tant que tel ne
présente aucun intérêt sur la ligne de
front c'est pas une ville importante
c'est pas un carrefour stratégique c'est
pas l'accès à une région que vont
s'offrir les Russes les Russes se sont
concentrés là c'est pour piéger
l'orgueil des Ukrainiens et leur dire
regardez vous n'arrivez pas à nous
empêcher d'avancer mais en fait pour
l'instant les Russes ont des pertes
terribles on avançant sur backmouth et
évidemment s'ils font ça s'ils se
permettent de faire ça on estime que ils
sont à des dizaines de milliers de tués
et blessés des quantités astronomiques
de munitions et de matériels qui sont
consommés comme vous le montrez très
bien sur les images pour une petite
ville avant de 60 70 000 habitants qui
me présente aucun intérêt particulier
c'était évidemment pour engager les
Ukrainiens dans une bataille qui aurait
été décisives et surtout empêcher les
Ukrainiens de pouvoir monter le fer de
lance que leur permet aujourd'hui
d'organiser les livraisons de matériel
blindés que leur envoient tous les pays
alliés dont le Canada et donc pour les
Ukrainiens c'est extrêmement important
d'un côté de montrer aux Russes que il
continue à les fixer et à se battre à
batmouth mais en réalité de préserver
leur force pour autre chose ok donc
voilà pas d'intérêt donc valeur
Guillaume en cell davantage symbolique
stratégique là vous le dites
alors attention une valeur symbolique
mais qui pourrait devenir stratégique si
les Ukrainiens commettaient l'erreur de
rentrer dans ce chaudron dans cette
mâchoire que l'auront tendu les Russes à
ce stade les informations que j'ai c'est
que les
Ukrainiens semblent avoir bien compris
la manoeuvre et qui se contente de se
retirer très progressivement vers
l'ouest de sortir sans laisser trop de
terrain aux Russes mais sans engager
leur force les plus importantes et
d'ailleurs il ne consacrent pas de
blinder moderne ou les fameux imas les
lance-roquettes multiples ou les canons
Césars français qui sont d'une extrême
précision non il les garde pour la
contre-offensive qui ne se passera
sûrement pas à backmout bon alors un
terminant Guillaume en scène
Poutine a besoin d'une victoire en
quelque part parce qu'il en charge
depuis six mois et est-ce que c'est pour
ça aussi qu'ils insistent très bon il y
a le piège que vous avez expliqué ils
insistent tant pour pouvoir dire voici
sur notre lit son embarquement
oui absolument Patrice c'est bien
l'objet en réalité backmout aujourd'hui
c'est surtout un objet dans la guerre de
la communication c'est ce qui doit
permettre à Poutine de dire en
particulier à son propre peuple qu'il
est en train de saigner pour cette
guerre plus de 100.000 morts du côté
russe donc c'est absolument dramatique
vous multipliez par 4 le nombre de
blessés donc on doit être entre 400 et
500 000 pertes du côté russe pour une
guerre qui ne mène absolument à rien et
donc c'est vital pour Poutine de montrer
que sa guerre avance parce que sinon son
propre pouvoir risque de vaciller et
c'est son propre régime qui se chargera
de le remplacer et sans doute pas avec
une retraite dorée aux îles Caïmans
de l'armée française écrivain d'ailleurs
votre livre vous avez un dernier livre
qui paraît je crois là vent glacial sur
Sarajevo publié aux Belles Lettres alors
je le dis en passant merci beaucoup à
très bientôt
merci Patrice bonsoir à tous salut
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI